au proche orient rentrée des classes ce
matin pour plus d'un million déconner
israélien avec l'instauration d'un
système de sécurité dans les territoires
les élèves palestiniens ont repris au
lui aussi le chemin de l'école d'hier
avec une apparence de normalité charanga
dans la crainte d'un attentat la rentrée
des classes se déroule en israël sous
très haute surveillance des policiers
renforce les vigiles armés qui durant
toute l'année scolaire garde l'entrée de
chaque école mais après deux années
d'intifada nerfs sécurité cela ne
rassure pas complètement les parents
j'espère que tout ira bien mais on a
toujours des craintes en raison d'une
grève des enseignants du secondaire
seuls les élèves du primaire ont repris
les cours
pas de grève mais des bouclages et des
couvre feu pour les écoliers
palestiniens
de nombreuses routes sont barrées par
l'armée israélienne et comme ici à l
rade air près de bethléem les enfants
qui habitent les villages avoisinants
doivent effectuer de longs trajets pied
je vais à l'école qui est très loin je
quitte la maison à 6 heures du matin
pour arriver à temps à 8 heures hélas
les classes sont surpeuplées l'unicef
l'organisation des nations unies pour la
protection de l'enfance apporte une aide
à douze mille petits palestiniens qui
n'ont pas les moyens d'acheter des
cartables et les nouveaux manuels
scolaires des livres qui font l'objet
depuis trois ans d'une révision
c'est dire donc plus rien à voir avec
les anciens niveau scolaire venait de
jordanie telit il ya donc plus du tout
d'incitation à la violence ou à la haine
dans ses livres la mairie mme sy fada
est omniprésent c'est un pichard appel
aux élèves qu'un de leur camarade a été
tués au cours des combats